When we all come together for a meal...
you appreciate it cause
it doesn't happen all the time.
Hey, Tom, that looks like
your first oyster right there.
That one right there?
That particular one?
Now, you just slurp it down. Yep.
That's really good.
I used to cook with Roy all the time
when he was training me,
and then the movie came out
and it all ended.
It's like being dumped.
It really was, it was like,
"When are we cooking again?"
How do you know when that's done?
I'm looking at the cheese.
I'm looking at the bottom.
I saw you in Chef making
that grilled cheese sandwich.
That's why I'm here.
That's crazy.
So much of our culture lives in our food.
And if you ate something growing up
and you have a taste for it,
you seek it out,
that's gonna keep that alive.
The food sticks with you.
Thank you for having us in your kitchen.
By the way,
do you guys curse on this show?
****I guess we just started doing it.